the FDA has granted emergency
authorization for a new type of
coronavirus test that could be cheaper
faster and simpler now it's called an
antigen test it looks for fragments of
virus proteins and samples collected
from the nasal cavity that sounds
Pleasant and it provides results in just
minutes but the FDA warns it has a
higher chance of false negatives our dr.
David agus joins us with more on this to
discuss David it almost sounds like a
good news bad news good news in that
there's a new test with quicker results
bad news in that you get a lot of false
negatives what do you think well this is
a very different test than the other one
the other one looked at RNA so this is
who has the virus looks at RNA in a very
complicated expensive machine and hours
later it comes up with the result this
is instantaneous looking for a protein
of the virus true there's a slightly
higher false negative right it's not
dramatically higher it's slightly higher
but the trade-off is you could do lots
of these inexpensively so when we talk
about testing the whole country which we
have to do this is the first of many
tests that will look at the antigen to
enable us to do this this actually is a
pretty big step forward you call it you
say it heralds a new era what do you
mean by that and what exactly does a
test show that's what I want to know
well this shows whether you have the
virus the other one looked at the RNA of
the virus and again it was more
complicated more expensive and harder to
do this one is relatively easy it is a
quick test that any technician can do
and it tells you yes or no you have the
virus very important when we want to
start to look at we call surveillance
testing across the country this enables
us to get to much higher numbers of
tests in the country when it's being
used we're also hearing word about a
home kit that tests your saliva what can
you tell us about that well given the
face you made we're given the face you
made when you said nasal swab I think
this is a good thing for you that is you
know you spit into a tube and it can be
done in the doctor's office or at home
to look for whether you have the virus
or not initially
you know swab in the nose the back of
the throat this is just as good and
certainly an advance at a Rutgers
University yeah you know David I've
heard that that nasal swab is very
unpleasant or uncomfortable which i
think is dr. code where this is gonna
hurt but when it comes to your health I
will do whatever you need to do it's put
on your big-girl pants and let's do it
now there's a new study that we're
hearing about it's a new combination of
three drugs that help relieve the
symptoms for patients with mild covin 19
markova 19 cases what are your thoughts
on this one it's pretty encouraging
right so the last study that showed a
benefit the first study that showed a
benefit with the drug was REM dis aveer
and severely or seriously ill patient
this is mild patients this is a drug for
HIV called Caleta a drug for hepatitis
called ripper Virant and a drug for
multiple sclerosis called beta
interferon put together and
significantly decrease the time virus
was present in the body compared to one
drug alone so we're making advances this
virus is druggable and it has weaknesses
that we're taking advantage of and I
think this is the beginning of what
you'll see is different drug regimens
that work and that makes our shoulders
get down come down I mean we actually
can treat this virus and hopefully and
stop people from going on ventilators in
the future okay before you go both the
president and the vice president said
they are not going to self isolate after
coming in contact with people on their
staff is that is that good it seems to
go against everything that we're being
told to do well we don't know exactly
how close or how long they were exposed
but I will say there's an expression to
get normative behavior change you need
leadership and I do think this was an
opportunity for both the president and
the vice president to show the country
how you behave in such situations so I
don't know their personal risk and it
may be the right decision but I think
this opportunity for leadership was
missed all right David agus thank you I
know we'll see you again very soon thank
you sir